I feel like some of it plays into this
larger story of the expectation that
that is what women are supposed to do or
like why aren't you married yet and it's
like first of all like my wife is fine
Tracee Ellis Ross is 45 and happily
single the star of ABC's blackish opens
up about her personal life for in styles
November cover story sharing that she's
content with her life just as it is
quote it's sort of fascinating to be 45
and single and childless happily single
I should add not at home crying about it
I'm very pleased with my existence these
days have I had to learn to make friends
with loneliness yes I think if I were in
a relationship it would be the same the
Golden Globe winner also gets real with
a mag about self-care and learning to
say no the I woke up like this thing
both blackish is an HD darling
there's no Vaseline on the lenses at 18
I might have woken up like this at 45 I
work for it I take care of myself
and by the way to me self-care does not
mean going to the spa
it's learning to say no it's knowing
yourself so you can make choices that
are an expression of you that's self
care Ross also opens up to the magazine
about her childhood and growing up the
daughter of legendary singer Diana Ross
it was very different being my mom's
child the attention was on her I was an
extension of someone that people loved
but finding my own my own take on all of
that in my own version has been a really
fun journey for me quote it's a lot it's
not navigable without a parent who is
choosing you over everyone else I grew
up the way Blue Ivy is growing up
although at least there wasn't social
media in 2014 Tracy opened up to ET
about the confidence her famous mama
instilled in her my mom gave me the
courage to really not shy away from Who
I am not shy away from what I loved not
shy away from
being seen you know nothing wrong with
that and sort of owning that I have
quiet and delicate in small moments too
but you know there's always a time for a
little glitter